it's bringing the great catcher the
hall-of-famer Johnny Bench Cincinnati
Reds Johnny how are you today
fantastic an answer on what did you guys
get for Valentine's I didn't get
anything that you get I didn't get
anything i but I didn't need anything so
colors it just it's just woman's
Valentine women's Valentine's Day I
think it's more the Woman's Day like I
don't expect anything you know my gift
is just giving back to everybody today I
mean that's showing my love for
everybody no I mean for goodness sake I
mean if I got a gift card for Home Depot
or for Dick's Sporting Goods or somebody
that would have been great I would have
been fine I could have done that I mean
it was just something remembrance of
what I've done in the past you poor guy
you need to take a stance in your own
house I can't help you out there they're
going to poor guy all right what do you
make I'm doing okay I'm doing a lot
better here you know about six six
months removed from treatment and you
know seeing these smiley faces
every single day the dead ends I mean
how could I wait I was being serious
Johnny
Berenice what did you think of yesterday
with the Astros I felt bad for Jim crane
I guess because I know him he's a nice
guy and I you know I doubt that he knew
anything about it I really do I think
you know with Lou now and AJ and they
just kind of cost him five million
dollars and two draft choices and stuff
and he's a quality individual and I just
you know he'll never recoup that from
those guys but I feel like that yeah and
the guys who you know they were
integrase they're good they'll do
anything they and they wanted all this
stuff and yet you know they their
denials are it's
going to satisfy you're never going to
satisfy media or people who are
naysayers or the Dodgers who suffered
through the Astros and then the Red Sox
and I feel bad for them because you know
it doesn't make a chance and who was
receiving those signals in the dugout
who was the guys that were whistling I
mean let's identify him they're the ones
that basically were delicious in all
this and they're the ones that were
responsible for getting the signs
whistling I mean if I knew what was
coming I'd hit seven hundred how does it
tell you right now we used to have it it
used to be a pitcher name a bill singer
the pitch for the Dodgers you add a
little slippery stuff every now and then
he'd put on that little cool fastlaner
grease or whatever you had it and he
denied it all the time but in the
all-star game in Kansas City for some
reason his jacket was lying there on the
bench and you know I'm having fun but
the Dodger jacket on and I reached in
the pocket and there was the there was
the Vassell and I say that story was
when he I couldn't hit him I mean I
couldn't hit him with a boat or he'd run
that sinker in on the or the slider away
then one day somebody from the dugout
said look I said what he said well when
he took those the curveball he takes it
any stretch he takes his hands for his
chin when he throws the slider he takes
it by his chest and when he throws the
fastball he does it at his waist he just
takes it puts the ball in the glove and
goes to the waist and I'm praying
somebody gets on well I had three
chances with guys on I had a two home
runs and a double and then some
ridiculous fella told him what he was
doing tipping yeah but you have the
owner of the Astros saying that this
didn't impact us winning the World
Series how's that possible Johnny then
why why do you fire your GM and your
manager and why are you being punished
by baseball if this didn't help you well
he already knew that I mean he can't
really believe that his players aren't
good enough to win
series so he's standing behind his
players on that fashion just saying hey
you know we would have want anyway
and that's that's what every owner
should believe that he's he's going to
say that because you know the easiest
thing in the world is try to well the
best thing in the world is trying to get
this as far behind you as you can and I
think they chose the right guy and Dusty
Baker to you know to offset some of the
media and also the critics and themself
and try to temper that and you know a
new guy would have a lot of problems
with it and best he'll just Slough it
off and say hey hey we're here to play
baseball and you guys let's just let's
just go at this and let's put it behind
this let's play but you know the corrupt
your pants we're never going to put it
behind them everyone they're going to do
everything they can but from the stands
and though you know if they let them
bring garbage cans yet that was
interesting because I never I I mean
I've never heard the garbage can out
heard the whistles because you guys have
brought it up and good and it was really
clear but somebody was getting the signs
and somebody was distributing them to
the hitter and somebody was whistling I
mean peanuts Lowry was the first base
coach for the San Francisco Giants and
he and certain cancers would have their
legs open enough to think it I he could
actually steal the signs and every time
he would he would get the science he
would give really a signal that he had
the science and if it'd been over it was
a fastball so every time every time
peanuts got a got the sign and got it to
Willie and will he hit a home run he got
a new suit I think I think peanuts had
27 suits that year
did somebody steal your signs I'm sure
they did you know and we were always
aware that somebody at second base was
the lien or the stand up or some kind of
motion that would you know indicate to
them that it was that's okay though
right that's baseball well you know you
just go out and you tell the pitcher
beforehand look I'm going to give you
the curveball sign don't pay any
attention to it just throw the fastball
writing is here
and once now the batter's up there and
he's looking for the curveball and he
gets the fastball up in hand under his
chin he said I'm not gonna trust these
guys I don't know what's coming
I remember when gene Mauch Pete they
couldn't get Pete out didn't matter he
they just got hit sit sit sit
so at the start of a game clay Dalrymple
was the catcher and he said gene said to
tell you what's coming he said all right
here's a fastball fastball right down
the middle Pete takes it all right now
you got a curveball he takes the curve
ball he steps out he steps out of the
box and tells them why would you tell
him but he didn't know the facts
I could still I could steal signs from
this by watching I mean steal a meaning
that I I would watch the pitcher and he
would always give a little something
he's with his glove he would flare the
glove open on his curveball he would
squeeze it tight if he brought it from
my around his side he'd come up with the
seams for the slider
he'd go cross thames with a fastball and
it was still hard to do but it's still
hard to hit but you know there were guys
that had telltale little things that
would give them away and and you tried
to get an edge as much as you could and
i hate to see what's happened with with
this but you know there was the Red Sox
and you know what other teams there's
other teams out there I'm sure that if I
mean they did it Wrigley Field in the
scoreboard
they did it in Boston in the scoreboard
so they were stealing signs is this is
that everybody could whistle right
Johnny Bench the Hall of Famer joining
us Dan Patrick show I mentioned this
yesterday the best in field including
the catcher of all time is the Big Red
Machine with you Perez Morgan concepción
and Rose I'm thinking who was the second
best infield in baseball history in your
opinion modern-day
you know the Dodgers weren't far behind
you know they had Garvey Lopes Russell
and say yeah it was kind of hard to be
and the Phillies were pretty darn good
with Smitty a third Bowl was it's a
short you know Dave cashew I think was
that their times and and yeah I mean I
would have to go back and you know you
would have to help me on that your
opinions but we were pretty good don't
be humble because we know that we know
Rose is a Hall of Fame caliber player
concepción to me was a Hall of Fame
shortstop you had Morgan and Perez and
then you which are obviously no down
Hall of Famers I also brought this up
too I said you might even agree with me
if the game is on the line
of all of those players on the
Cincinnati Reds the one guy you would
want at the plate with the game on the
line was Tony Perez yeah I want a but
yeah I'm taking you out of this but
Perez was a great a great clutch hitter
yeah yeah and and Joe may have been the
best player I've ever seen ever period
better than anybody Mays man Toby I mean
that whole group Joe Morgan was the best
player you ever saw yeah he could get a
hit he could take a walk he steal a base
you get it home run and he was gonna go
on to go glove yeah I don't know if we
were the best we were among the top two
let me just say that what infield yeah I
know for us but I I got a Hall of Famer
at every position basically I know I
know it's it's pretty amazing and that
to put together a team that like and how
much would you have to pay today you
couldn't keep you guys together in
Cincinnati no no it was you know a
couple of us you know we'd all be over
the wells in the twenties hundred
million
what was the most you ever made nine
hundred nine hundred thousand I made 2.2
in my entire career Wow
I made eleven thousand my first year
which was a thousand above the minimum I
won the Rookie of the Year I made 20 on
MVP made 40 Oh on MVP again I made 80
and then I had the lung surgery and
which kind of slowed everything down so
Gerrit Cole will make the amount of
money you made in your career in the
month of April no in the first two weeks
of it
I mean it's four million a month I mean
easy and makes more than that so he's
making more than that and I know he's
got a tenner to 11 day grace period so
it's great to hear from you talk about
the steroids yeah thank you yeah you're
just you guys are guys worth a hundred
million dollars now for do you think
it's how important their Hall of Fame
would be but they're living the life and
I don't think I don't think bonds or
Clements has any remorse if they don't
make it in the Hall of Fame the amount
of money they made in the second half of
their career the twilight of their
careers you know I'm sure they look at
it sales guys in the last few years that
have been tied to steroids and they're
in and I think they're just making a
make of a sort of a thing about about
Clemens Anne and Anne bond so I think
they're trying to make examples do you
think that they're going to get those
guys are going to get in yeah I do now
how do you feel
I'm you know I'm I'm in-between I mean I
you know when I remember when Frank
Robinson
I think the first meeting they ever had
and they said this isn't for the very
good this is for the great
oh the whole name so yeah so I'm I like
the guys personally it's it's hard to
deal with it's hard for us to live with
but I think with the last few years and
everything else with people with shadows
over their careers and stuff
I think it's it'll be interesting so
I'll go with the sports writers if they
decide to do it which they haven't but
I'll be at all of Fame and wait for your
induction great to hear from you Johnny
thank you very much and good luck today
well yeah thank you buddy that's Johnny
Bench hall-of-famer for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]